hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
april 4th
2022
[Music]
i cannot believe april 4th is here
um
this is the final shoot day
it was supposed to be we got a little
something we got to do tomorrow but like
i'm we're gonna be wrapped on this movie
i can't believe it i had so much fun
doing it
um and now of course you know take a
week off then we gotta start editing the
thing but um
i can't believe we got here it seems
like uh went by fast and it also feels
like it took 30 years
i had an awesome time
and oh
am i looking forward
to getting out and doing some stand up
dates oh billy [ __ ] talk
oh freckled fury is coming your way i'm
gonna be in birmingham alabama alabama
on thursday
would that be april 8th and then friday
april 9th i'm going to be in macon
georgia
georgia oh georgia
you look down oh i got the nut the dates
wrong thursday april 7th i'll be in
birmingham alabama
and then in uh friday
april 8 i'll be in uh macon georgia
all right and i am planning on like i am
i cannot [ __ ]
wait
to be involved in something where you do
it once and how it came out is what it
is and we're moving on
something that exists
in real time
you want an hour of comedy it takes 60
minutes
i was so excited today it's sunday night
getting to ready to do the last day and
a half on this movie
uh club soda kenny was lit was driving
me down the street and i was literally
had my head out the window like ace
ventura just going whoa
the whole [ __ ] way and you know what
you know what i'm gonna smoke a [ __ ]
cigar tonight look at the lines
and the shots we have to do tomorrow
and
um and then i'm gonna start putting this
thing together but uh
what what an experience i learned so
much
learned so much so anyway
a lot of things have happened all my kid
my son's crying down there i gotta try
to sneak this podcast in it's probably
gonna be in two parts
he's gonna cry like that that makes me
feel bad
um
oh that's the cry he does when
something's taken away from him
um anyway uh shout out
to north carolina tar heels
and the kansas jayhawks
for making it to the championship game
which will be played tonight to decide
who is the greatest basketball team in
the ncaa for
2021-2022
um congratulations to the carolina tar
heels
uh
beating duke
the last two times coach k was gonna
play him that's the only thing
that hurts as a uh a fan of greatness a
fan of of uh
you know college coaches professional
coaches you gotta love a legendary coach
and um i feel like coach k is up there
on the top shelf and uh was tough to see
him lose to carolina twice
but carolina deserved it they won the
game and um
i mean one of the greatest coaching
careers in any sport transcended his
sport
shout out to coach k
shashefsky um i can't tell you how many
times i learned how to spell that and
then immediately forgot um
and carolina versus kansas two other
programs that i absolutely love who you
going for bill i don't know i got to go
with kansas i think
you know it's one of my uh bucket list
things is to go to the game and do a
game there or what they call it the uh
the field house or whatever i gotta go
to that
and uh north carolina i've never been to
a carolina basketball game in the dean
dome
um i gotta do that also and uh
yeah i told you i have this weird thing
where i i like carolina and i like duke
and i went to nc state for a couple of
semesters took a few classes before
you know i realized i just
was not on the path i needed to be on
nothing against nc state but i remember
being down there going to daryl's
restaurant right there down there on
whatever the [ __ ] street that was
hillsborough
um that's back when they had child
shackleford
chucky brown right
something like that i was trying to
remember their team
um and also when the end zone seats were
grass because i went to an nc state game
way back in the day they went to
reynolds coliseum
i saw uh
who did i see there so aerosmith
on the permanent vacation tour and i saw
def leppard
on the done with me uh on the dumb
mirrors on the um
hysteria toy you know what i i got my
kids flipping out i got i got to handle
this [ __ ] i'll be back in a second
all right i'm back
tragedy averted i knew he wasn't crying
that was this
something else cry he wasn't hurt he had
a cookie and then he wanted another one
and he got the heisman so he was not
happy anyway
uh what was i talking about baseball
season is starting wrapping on the movie
birmingham making georgia we got all of
that [ __ ] going on
this will be my last monday morning
podcast slider
as of next week they'll go back to being
an hour long um
so let's do some of the reads for the
week man let's see what we got here what
are people saying
uh oh by the way are the celtics in like
first place in the east is that what
somebody tried to tell me
i watched the end of uh
some game indiana jesus christ both
teams were shooting the lights out
let's check out the uh the nba standings
there
nba
standings okay here we go what do we got
here
we're a second seed get the [ __ ] out of
here
we must have been we've got on a 8-2
tear right there
must have done that a couple of times
last i saw we were in the middle of the
pack i know we got the milwaukee bucks
coming up and the 76ers so big
test early before the blast we'll see
how it goes um
all right so people wrote in i was
talking about having mashed potatoes
on thanksgiving
which is a white person staple
it you know when you go outside the
arena there people are looking at you
like what's going on here so people are
weighing in on mashed potato what's up
old billy tater tits
lady listener here and i'm [ __ ] here
i wanted to share my love for mashed
potatoes and the absolute horror i had
at my first thanksgiving with my
boyfriend now husband's family
i'm a white chick mostly italian and
irish my husband is puerto rican now to
me mashed potatoes are a must at
thanksgiving it just is
it is with the [ __ ] gravy the [ __ ]
turkey and the stuffing that's that's
the triangle offense
you gotta have the cranberries
you know
and you go from there oh max
mac and cheese whatever top it off with
some stuffing and gravy oh my god it's a
party that's it that's it
so we get uh to his family's house and
i'm looking around for mashed potatoes
and i don't see any my husband brings me
over to the mashed potatoes and it's
[ __ ] potato salad ah
half shmoosh potatoes with mayonnaise
and eggs
what are we at a [ __ ] barbecue
do they they got hot dogs over there
what's going on don't get me wrong i
love me some potato salad i actually
don't
potato salad for me lives in the
coleslaw world
uh coleslaw
i'll always look at coleslaw with the
side eye i have to be honest young
people have to understand this coleslaw
you're eating today is not the coleslaw
that people grew up with coleslaw when i
was growing up with was limp it was
milky it was [ __ ] gross you know what
it really was it was a it was a plate
filler
it was like when you went to a
restaurant
and they wanted to act like they gave
you two [ __ ] sides and fill up the
whole plate they gave you a big helping
of coleslaw and it [ __ ] sucked
finally
you know this [ __ ] with leak india other
food it was just a nasty
virus of a food but now people have
learned to learn how to make it hearty
so but uh i would say potato salad
i don't know i've just i've never really
had a good one
it's just sort of like i like potatoes
you know i like mayonnaise i like eggs i
don't like it all together
anyway don't get me wrong i love me some
potato salad but that's a summer dish
apparently this is a spanish thing
because i asked all of my puerto rican
friends later
and they agreed that those are mashed
potatoes
those are not mashed potatoes they're
cut up potatoes
they're not mashed so now every
thanksgiving we argue over the fact that
those are not true mashed potatoes and i
bring the white people potatoes so i can
happily stuff my pasty ass with its
deliciousness
has anything like that ever happen to
you and the beautiful nia
p.s stop being insecure nia is right
the ladies love them some billy burr
i don't know what that's referencing um
anyway uh as far as the potatoes go uh
yeah that mashed potatoes
you just gotta at some point you just
have to understand that like you know
there's gonna be some confusion in the
world
you know people travel it's the
telephone game
so i guess uh
puerto ricans called potato sat what we
call potato salad
mashed potatoes we call mashed potatoes
mashed potatoes
whatever the [ __ ] it is i don't know
um
i like potatoes so i will tell you that
i do and i gotta be honest with potato
salad is the one kind of potato i don't
like
anything else you know the potatoes in
the clam chowder which i was not a fan
of clam chowder
i never liked it to me it always looked
like that [ __ ] a cow pukes up when it's
going from stomach number one to stomach
number two i thought it was gross
it just was always just
warm yucky
didn't like it
until i got little kids i literally just
said yucky
it was [ __ ] disgusting there is that
adult enough for you and then i go down
to uh manhattan no they put a little
tomato [ __ ] sauce in it all right let
me try this for terrible
terrible now you know the cow puked and
then had a period oh bill what are you
doing sorry but i had a great
i had a hearty
clam chowder the other day it was like
rained out here and ate everything and
uh i had a really good one so the
potatoes and that i like i like the
fried potatoes i like the tater tots oh
billy potato face here gonna go through
all of it the only type of potato i i
just don't like [ __ ] potato salad
all right
so there you go
you know a little insight on me
you know
uh sweet potatoes i like you know f1
dear bill your take on british formula
one commentators was so spot on and so
funny that's funny because the lewis
hamilton fans a couple of them got on me
uh
they think i don't like the guy i'm just
you know whatever it's like when i get
into college football i start trash in
alabama i'm not gonna just start rooting
for them uh did you know these
commentators are just using a template
made by the legendary f1 commentator a
legendary f1 commentator named murray
walker
i have to look this guy up he's this
person says when i first started
watching f1 with my dad murray was
paired with world champion driver and
shagger
james hunt
jesus that guy lived a life huh murray's
voice would go helium pitched with
enthusiasm and he'd often get his facts
wrong in his excitement james hunt on
the other hand was calm and would coolly
correct murray but always showed the
veteran race commentator respect
well this james hunt sounds like the
coolest dude ever uh murray was also a
humble man and sent set him
set himself up brilliantly in a pizza
hut
oh sent himself up brilliantly made fun
of himself in a pizza hut advertisement
with damon hill link below i did have
some thoughts on fried chicken and
mashed potatoes too but i'm sure you're
sick of my voice already thanks for all
the laughs and warm regards to your
family well let me see
if i can find this link here i can at
least tell you guys
what it is
i can tell you
what it is um
great emails
scrolling down and
damon hill
it just says damon hill pizza
advertisement here we go
let's
see it's go and damon hill leans into
the first bend
marie there's been a shunt it's hell no
we're just out for quiet oh i get it
he's just gonna be screaming like that
it's not gonna make any sense unless you
know who the [ __ ] he is and you're
watching the thing i get it
and lewis hamilton
um kayaking the english channel [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] that
there's a bunch of drunk [ __ ] out there
on boats we'll slice you in half
um
wait a minute i'm thinking of the tames
is that how you say it the [ __ ] river
the dirty river of london um you're
talking about going from england to
france [ __ ] that
hey billy red bullocks firstly thanks
for the laughs long time listener love
your podcast your stand-ups and your
work in general thank you not looking
for advice but for words of
encouragement encouragement my friend
paul and i are kayaking the english
channel this summer
as someone who can barely swim and is
somewhat
the lassophobic
would you have any words of
encouragement for me what is the
lassophobic
i gotta look this up
the last
is this really a thing are you [ __ ]
with me
thalassophobic
uh is a type of specific phobia that
involves a persistent and intense fear
of deep bodies of water
such as oceans or seas
oh look at that i didn't know i had that
i don't know it's not it's not a
persistent and intense fear it's just
when somebody asked me to go i'm like
yeah [ __ ] that
you know
how about it's a wrist i have a respect
for the ocean in the seat the same way i
do lions and tigers you want to go into
the jungle with his lions and tires no
[ __ ] that um anyway i've been hitting
the gym every day since october
in preparation lost over three stone in
weight
jesus i always have to look this up what
the [ __ ] is a stone
stone
in pounds
all right what do we got here
one stone equals 14 pounds
this son of a [ __ ] what's that 14 times
3 is 42 pounds good for you
um i'm in the best shape of my life at
nearly 40 years old we will also have a
support boat with us during the crossing
oh that's cool then so it'll be
relatively safe is there any sort of
adventure like this that you would ever
consider doing keep up the great work
you know what i always wanted to do i
always wanted to ride a bicycle for one
leg of the tour de france
um
i wanted to take batting practice at
fenway park yeah i got a bunch of these
things that i would love to do
um
but yeah i think you know riding a bike
now i think i'm too [ __ ] old to do
that
oh billy's too old to get back in the
saddle there
i have to [ __ ] ice my taint for like
a [ __ ] three-week period after that
but uh it is something that i always
like when um i would watch the tour de
france growing up i just always loved
when you know they would go through like
those countryside towns
i always just thought that would be a
great thing even if you just wrote a
third of it i think it would be really
cool um all right made in america
uh all right so i was talking about this
stuff where i was like hey why don't we
talk about
some [ __ ] that's actually made over here
i was talking about um
shinola
and they make all of this stuff bicycles
and stuff i almost bought one of their
bikes but i was like what am i gonna do
with that [ __ ] thing but i did buy
one of their watches
um
okay uh made in america
el
trera a-l-t-r-a-r
wait a-l-t-r-a-r-a
hi bill i just listened to your podcast
love it as always we are a an american
company making stuff in san diego
california one of the coolest places
chillest places you'll ever [ __ ] go
to unless you wear a new england
patriots hat uh we are two engineers
bootstrapping a company
so that we can eventually get out of the
rat race and do our own thing our app
platform and sensors enable enable
people to monitor and control things
from their from their phone
of course now i get hiccups
um our staff lets people know that their
cars
van life rv and or other
and or slash off the grid campsites are
ready to go 24 7. get notified of dead
batteries fridges that are warm or stuff
that has been moved
we currently have a battery monitoring
sensor temperature sensor and movement
sensor
we 3d print the boxes for these sensors
as well as
solder the boards up
and assemble them here in san diego we
also developed the software
uh
works with android and i think apple and
cloud technology here we will have be
having a launching party slash booth at
the adventure van expo
in san juan
capistrano this april 30th thanks for
giving a shout out
of our made in america stuff on your
show yeah no worries that sounds like
some cool [ __ ] a lot of people like
to hunt and do all of that stuff i
should let the
bobby kelly know about it oh bobby
oh [ __ ] bobby trout
trout pants bobby [ __ ] uh
bakersfield oh bobby campsite
um all right made in america
playing cards
bill fellow new englander here really
enjoyed the podcast and like your
support of american-made products my
retail site playingcarddex.com
offers the words world's largest
selection of playing cards and all of
the decks we produce are made in the usa
by united states playing card company in
kentucky in business since 1865.
you can check out some of our decks here
playing card decks
dot com
let me see were you just talking about
52 pick up here what are we talking you
got the
the old playboy ones with the [ __ ]
titty cards you used to have dirty cards
back in the day oh look at they got all
different kinds
all different kinds how about some
pictures with my slow ass internet
oh these are the bicycle ones
playing cards here
hannah fudas stripe striper that said
stripper
those are birds
well these [ __ ] cool i don't know you
get all these different types of playing
cards they got a jolly rogers
gilded bicycle playing that's a badass
one
that is cool deck of cards
deck of cards is cool even though
everybody [ __ ] plays it on their
phone now
uh i might buy some [ __ ] from this
playing card decks that's pretty cool um
all right
this is the last one i'm gonna read here
what do we got
made in america pilot glasses
for all you [ __ ] aviators
oh billy wright brother burr
uh i've been a long time listener of the
podcast i saw you perform in my alma
mater embry riddle a few years ago a few
years back you killed
uh three years ago i started a small
business called scanners
pilot irfr training glasses
like the foggles right to help
pay back my student loans as a way to
contribute to the aviation community i
hand make customized pilot instrument
training glasses the glasses hood that
student pilots wear to simulate imc
conditions generally known as foggles i
first made them when i was a flight
instructor as a way to make my students
feel more comfortable in the car pick i
make the flight lessons and make the
flight lessons more enjoyable i
currently partner with my scholarship
programs like girls love to fly and
women with wings as well as other
communities that help student pilots
with the cost of training scanners have
also been featured in uh
aopa pilot magazine oh they're not just
super cool looking but since i use
a cover film they also block out the
glare from making and making it easier
to see your instruments i want a pair of
these if you had sunrise or sunset
flight with them on i'm sure you know
what i'm talking about anyway
you can see all the designs i make here
the us
at scanners ifr
or on social media
it's at scanners ifr glasses i
appreciate you giving me a reason to
write in i don't have the money to do
any marketing myself so i appreciate the
shout out every bit helps keep up the
great work uh safe flying and go [ __ ]
yourself a fellow aviator i gotta tell
you the foggles that i have suck
big goofy plastic ones
um that make the side of your head hurt
hold on a second let me look at the
scanners ifr.com
scanners
you [ __ ] pill come on scanners if
ifr.com
let's see what comes up here what do you
say there scanners
uh number one
rated viewing pilots shop now
oh look at those
they're only 23 bucks
dude those are badass and they look
comfortable as hell
i'm sending this to every pilot i know
those are fantastic fam when do i when
you ever hear me say fantastic see this
is great
helping people out
um
and in turn they help you out i believe
they call it paying it forward all right
let's do a little advertising here as i
just [ __ ] basically was doing
advertising there roman
you know when the moment for intimacy
arrives
when you want to stick your noodle in
the sauce there oh geez uh you need to
be ready roman ready whether you've been
in a relationship for years or just
getting started having the confidence
that comes from preparation means you're
free to enjoy the moment when the moment
comes even though you are far from
ordinary the truth is that erectile
dysfunction is really common in fact 52
percent of
guys age 40 to 7 70 experience some form
of
erectile dysfunction
uh go to get roman.com burn now to speak
to a u.s licensed health care
professional about erectile dysfunction
and get 15 off your first month of
treatment uh the benefits of ed
treatment can help you reconnect with
your partner and rediscover the joy of
sex roman ready is confidence
personified it is the self-assurance
that comes from knowing you've prepared
yourself for the moment when intimacy
arrives roman's system is completely
confidential and totally discreet no big
logos or labels on packages with roman
you can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for
for what everybody say with me erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home the whole process
is straightforward convenient and
discreet getting started is simple just
go to getroman.com
and complete an online visit take care
of your e.d without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with the u.s licensed health
care professional and take care of it go
to get roman
g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
b-u-r-r today and if you're prescribed
get 15 off your first month of ed
treatment make sure you're ready to have
confidence in control this fall with
roman ready and go out and handle your
erectile dysfunction
all right lastly but not leastly oh look
who it is stamps.com
all faithful
right at dicedamps.com you know time is
money
don't waste either with repeated trips
to the post office with stamps.com you
can skip the trip and focus on how to
take your small business to the next
level stamps.com lets you print official
postage right from your computer and
saves you money in the process so you
can spend less money at the post office
and more time making your customers
happy uh you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over nine years now and if you
have if you haven't tried it what are
you waiting for stamps.com saves you
time money and stress
and get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to forty percent
off usps rates and 76 off ups whether
you're an office sending invoices a side
hustle etsy shop or a full-blown
warehouse shipping out orders stamps.com
will make your life easier all you need
is a computer standard printer no
special supplies or equipment stop
overpaying for shipping with stamps.com
sign up with the promo code bur b-u-r-r
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and enter code bur b u
r
r all right and now lastly but certainly
not leastly um i want to thank all you
guys for the patience you've had over
the last month
um well i've been doing this movie um
and still listening to the shorter
podcast i really appreciate it all right
um we have this other topic badass [ __ ]
what's the what's some badass [ __ ] that
you bought that's secretly in the back
of your mind you know you're not bad ass
enough to own
all right for me it's a gibson les paul
all right badass [ __ ] i told my friend
not to buy
dear billy gibson in college there was a
guy who played guitar in my hallway i
play guitar too so i had some insight
into my
insight into my advice to him when he
said he was going to buy a double neck
sg don't get me wrong i wanted him to
get it so i could play it occasionally
but i knew it was a horrible purchase he
was a pretty good guitar player he
didn't suck but he wasn't pushing
virtuoso status and wasn't about to
change the game with the double neck i
told him in my opinion it's a
performance guitar and really not fun to
play in your room and suggested he just
get a 12 string
uh in the end he got it and it was a
bust he played it at one open mic show
and it was kind of out of tune brutal i
played it a bit and it was cool
he had fun with it too but mostly any
time i saw it in his room it was
collecting dust because it's not
fun to play sitting down he sold it at
the end of the year but didn't make
but didn't take much of a loss
yeah you know what
but he can say he owned one you know
and he played it you got to play it too
so that's not too bad i i had a 70 or a
71 green sparkle ludwig kick all bottom
sizes
with the ludwig speed king i did the
whole bottom thing and you know i played
it live at the [ __ ] roxy i had a
[ __ ] blast but like
i mean
the kit just wasn't me and i just ended
up i had the bottom symbols the whole
[ __ ] setup and i just sold the whole
thing and it was the best thing i ever
did for my drumming
because i was really just going down a
route of like just
being yet another ripoff
you know of john bonham john bonham
didn't go out and [ __ ]
you know start [ __ ] oh this guy
played this i mean i mean i guess
everybody played ludwig back in the day
but he got the kit that was right for
him
um
that's what you have to do but having
said that it was fun to own the thing
and uh
you know having a double neck guitar is
pretty cool i'm immediately picturing
the jimmy page one
i always thought that that was sick and
then there's a guy from cheap trick
where he had the most i ever saw because
then there was the triple guitar and
then there was four and he had like a
five or a six
it was insane like it started at like
his chest and went all the way down to
his knees
um
but anyway yeah you probably gave him
good advice but everyone you're young
you got to do something dumb
like buy an old muscle car that needs a
lot of [ __ ] work just to say you had
one and you don't have the money to fix
it up no one in the back of your head
that it's going to break down when you
really need it but you know just to do
it i say do it all right that's it
everybody
um
next monday we go back to the hour-long
monday morning podcast hopefully i'll
have figured out my interface with my
computer and all of that [ __ ] so enough
to keep recording them on my phone
um
i am so [ __ ] excited
uh that this movie is going to be
wrapped and i can start putting it
together because the performances in
this movie um i think
you know are going to be great i don't
want to talk too much [ __ ] but i think i
got a really good
a really good um
movie also we shall see so that is it uh
enjoy the game tonight
uh between kansas and uh north carolina
that is all and i will uh check in on
you guys on thursday okay